luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start guys and welcome back
to the leia highlands show powered by icon
plus capital the vc firm as always it is sponsored
by blockfy you can get up to 250 when you sign up
so that is pretty cool um before we jump in i do
have a new sponsor this month so i just want to
let you guys know who it is otherwise we won't
be able to have these amazing conversations so
this episode is sponsored by compass mining the
company that makes bitcoin money accessible for
everyone you just buy your machine pick a
hosting facility and let them do the work so
if you want to start mining bitcoin then you just
need to head to compass mining.io which is pretty
cool because mining bitcoin is expensive so
joining me today is bernard parra the ceo
of bit knob bernard welcome to the show i can
see that you are on mute so just unmute yourself
oh no do we have do we have a connection problem
let's see maybe if i remove
bernard and bring him back in
okay so while we try and
get bernie to come back in
basically today is a really interesting show
we are talking about bitcoin in nigeria um
there are a lot of different restrictions
um and problems and a lot of reasons people
are turning to bitcoin um in this part of the
world so i wanted to get bernard on the show
but it looks like we're having a problem all right
maybe i will drop him a message and see what is up
i'm having really bad luck with uh with
my live shows oh there we go is he back
bernard we can't really hear you or see you
okay guys let me know if it's me or bernard okay
i think it's can you hear me okay i'm having a
lot of bad luck with my shows i actually had
um michaela peterson on the other day and um
as soon as we were talking about tick tock
the show just crashed well she had a power
cut which was totally random okay i think we have
bernard back let's have a look there we go what
happened i think i lost my connection but i'm good
you're good so welcome to the show how are you
ah thank you how are you doing i'm good i'm glad
that i have you back i was stressing for a moment
how are you yeah i'm good happy to be here yeah
well listen i came across your profile because
i saw you did this long tweet which totally
blew up i think he got around 14 000 likes um
talking about why bitcoin is really really
necessary in nigeria um so before we jump
into that tell us a little bit about yourself
because you are obviously the ceo of bitknob so
tell us about that yeah yeah so thank you for
having me once again um my name is bernard para
ceo and co-founder of bidnog software engineering
background you know and we've been what we're
doing is basically you know um reducing the
barrier to access uh you know bitcoin and um
you know cryptocurrencies like stable coins
to nigerians and africans at large you know
um over time it's been like really expensive for
people to get these assets um you know do you have
peculiar challenges over here and whatnot and we
believe that democratizing access to assets like
this it's a really important mission and that's
that's the most important thing for us right now
and what we're doing at bit knob yeah i think it's
honestly amazing so um for those that don't know
um burn it is based in nigeria right now and one
of the main things that got me really hooked on
this space and i say this all the time was how
and i will say blockchain technology and bitcoin
is essentially saving lives in many different
parts of the world creating better quality of life
helping people giving them an economic fighting
chance that is actually what really hooked me
so from your perspective i really want to know
if you could just break it down for us what are
some of the key problems in nigeria and why you
feel you need a new system yeah i think the first
one is um capital controls currency controls so
for example right now you can't really use more
than a hundred dollars you know uh out of your
debit card to you know buy things online so just
think about it you've you've gone
to work you've earned some money and
um you know you can you can't even spend it online
right you need to you know find ways around that
which is not good it's basically taking your
freedom from you um you know the other things
are things like inflation so nigeria's
inflation is currently at um 16.5 percent
that's like that's absolute that's very high
right um nigeria's the nigerian era has lost
i mean more than 30 percent of its value
against the us dollar in the past one year
um it's really crazy so in real time we're seeing
the cost of things going up and it's just it
just looks like there's no way out right and um
bitcoin just gives us that kind of alternative
and of course investment opportunities as well so
of course everyone is looking to get wealthy um
but to get things like stocks and all of
those things are kind of pretty expensive
for every but for everyone to get in right uh
things like bitcoin bitcoin just democratizes that
access to it you can easily exchange it as an
asset with anyone around the world and you know
and we're seeing pretty interesting things as
well around the censorship resistance space
so we've seen people's uh bank accounts getting
locked because they were blocked because he did
something maybe the government doesn't want and
it's basically just taking your freedom that's
basically just taking your freedom away from you
when you look at it so fundamentally uh bitcoin is
um freedom to to us it gives us that alternative
uh to the current system okay so here's my thing
you mentioned three really insane things okay
firstly i'm just gonna repeat this in case anybody
didn't catch because your internet is going in and
out um a bit so bernard was saying that there is
a 100 a day limit on online spending a month a
month oh my god a month i'm sorry i missed that
why my thing is why why how is that justified i
mean it's um it's basically forex controls right
so for these banks to make those international
payments for you they need to find um you know
they need to get the dollar equivalent to
make those international payments for you
so basically just capital controls that uh to
reduce the outflow of um dollars from the economy
wow honestly i'm really taken back i didn't
realize i thought it was i thought it was
a day so thank you for clarifying that so
inflation is around 16 why is that happening
i think it's a it's a couple of factors so the
first factor is um nigeria is more of a consuming
economy right um we import we import almost
everything right um from china from the u.s
muslim imports driven uh economy and um
also a huge part of our gdp as well you know
it's based on oil and we know how the oil prices
have been in the past um yeah as well so you look
at other government policies for example um in the
past one two years the government locked uh closed
down the borders so you couldn't really
you know you can't import things so they
there's this rice in food because food inflation
itself is like more than 20 percent as we speak
right so of course there's food
production is low within the country
uh you can't really import things as well from
abroad it's really expensive to do that um
getting effects as well depleting foreign reserves
you know just a lot of factors that just you know
make it just uh it's just crazy just those are
like key factors mostly government policies but
what i don't understand is like when you look at
the country and you look at these spending limits
and you look at how it's badly affecting people's
lives you know in terms of entrepreneurship and
just being able to do business with the rest
of the world which is so important you know
to basically just changing your life why would
they make it so difficult it sounds like it's
done on purpose i mean am i missing something
here for me i just i can't understand why
i mean about control i'm sorry if
it's unfair but is it about control
um so so we we like to think of it in two ways
down here in africa right um we like to see them
first as a failure of leadership right basically
you know you know um certain set of people just
wanting to stick to the old way of doing things
not wanting to you know move uh with the time with
the times and everything and of course there's a
part of control right yeah when you look at on the
nsa's protest as well and uh why people's accounts
were getting blocked uh you know for contributing
for donating to the process was it was a thing
of control right because it looked like ah this
this young guys are coming to you know move us out
of of power and everything that's what he saw he
saw that's a power as a power game right yeah and
um when jack tweeted about bitcoin and you know
it just kind of spooked them and like took them to
the next level of fear anxiety and everything and
then their actions from then on where are like
really brutal so there's aspect of control and
when you look at it uh bitcoin basically is coming
to take you know control out of you know existing
systems like this right to give you an alternative
to opt out of these systems so so that's that's
a bit in control and just uh you know old man
sticking to the audio of doing things yeah i mean
i've spoken to um a lot of different ceos based
out of nigeria because there are a lot of people
in this industry trying to help and make a better
life and every single time i hear about this i you
know it just really blows my mind and it really
warms my heart that there's a solution truly
um so from your standpoint when did you first hear
about bitcoin well sometime in uh i think november
of 2013 um long time ago yeah yeah but how what
happened um yeah so first first i saw it online
i think um if i remember correctly something
around all these silk road um case and stuff
raws and all of that and then um later i heard
one of my classmates in school talking about it
you know and it's like he's got some bitcoin
and stuff i'm like uh how does he do it what
does he do is like he sells it he makes money uh
from it's right and i'm like oh cool um so i had
done all that kind of um digital stuff before
liberty reserve all those kind of things so
the concept of selling digital currencies online
basically just clicked and started getting some
from him and also reselling i basically
just kept on doing that uh you know before
you know sometime in 2016 started building um
you know crypto applications bitcoin applications
uh you know for companies around here yeah so
is it difficult then is it difficult to build a
cryptocurrency business in
nigeria are there restrictions
yeah it's um it's very difficult the funny thing
is at a point in time it felt like the easiest
thing to do right oh yes there were no um there
were no clear-cut regulations you didn't need any
special kind of license you need to adjust it
free for all you know just set up your website
and just get people to trust you and come and buy
bitcoin from and that was it right um it felt like
the easiest thing to do but right now you know
when you do it you're on your own right so you
can't get uh official banking partnerships so
you can't have an official bank account here you
can't you know have a payment processor helping
you collect uh funds you know servers on-ramp or
off-ramp for you so it's um it's really difficult
it just keeps getting more difficult but um i
mean we're welding a lot we're learning to be more
anti-fragile and you know just build for the world
yeah the restrictions um have become more intense
in nigeria um and this year particularly it really
sparked my interest because there was a ban right
the ban was that major well not even major just
institutional banks weren't allowed to on board
sorry weren't allowed to facilitate cryptocurrency
exchanges but apparently that but then somebody
came out and sort of said well actually no that's
not true it was just reinforcing something from
a few years ago so there's been a lot of u-turns
it's confusing can you explain what the current
regulations are and what you can and can't do
yeah i mean i mean um the first of such kind
of um you know what they call it warnings or
guidance was yeah sometimes sometime in 2017 if i
remember correctly or late yeah 2016 when um the
mmm uh who this ponzi scheme called mmm was very
you know come on down here right and according
to central bank that's just what they've been
doing they've just been reiterating that um
this is not officially recognized in the country
and you know they've never actually went out like
directly to see you know financial institutions
shouldn't do anything with crypto companies right
but um this time so they didn't say that oh this
time they did it right yeah they did this time
they did this decent day the guardians was really
clear that uh looking for a payment processor you
can overcome with crypto companies uh as well so i
mean right now of course bitcoin cryptocurrencies
are not illegal in nigeria you can still trade
you can still use them for your transactions
you consider whatever you want to do with them
but if for example you are starting an exchange
you can't have a bank account you can have a
payment processor there are no as it stands there
still no clear-cut regulations right from the sec
yeah it's kind of um we're seeing different tones
from the sec the central bank and the ministry
of information and technology it's really kind
of these ones are looking this way and these
ones are looking this way and then it's it's
they're just dilly dilling like there's really
no clarity when it comes to distance right now
i think that's the point though isn't it to make
it really difficult just off topic for a second
sort of reminds me with what's going on in the
uk with kovid they've made it so difficult to
understand what the travel rules are and the
travel restrictions are so you just don't end
up getting involved because one person says this
another one says that so you just give up entirely
um so how do you buy business yes yeah it is it's
it really really is just make things as confusing
as possible yeah um unbelievable so how do you
buy bitcoin then yeah so um of course the most
popular way of buying bitcoin right now is um
you know peer-to-peer transactions um either on
platforms or in whatsapp groups or just someone
you know directly right but wait sorry yeah throw
it into rupturing but that would require somebody
else in nigeria to want to sell their bitcoin
what if they don't want to i mean
um if you go to platforms that
you know all these transactions like paxo
you're definitely going to get someone who
who is looking to sell some bitcoin for you
right either the person is doing some form
of remittances through paxful wants
to liquidate their bitcoin for fiat
you definitely get someone who wants to do it
and of course there are a lot of groups as well
uh you know where they've been there for a
long time some since 2016 they've been there
there's that reputation you can just go in and
that means you know if we facilitate a trade
between you and whoever um the other way is um
and that's one of the things we use at bitno is
um uh through vouchers so people just buy um these
digital vouchers and then are able to redeem it
for bitcoin so those are like the two major
ways um people can actually buy bitcoins uh
in nigeria right now i'd love to hear your
thoughts about i guess really just global
sentiment towards bitcoin because it's heating
up i mean even in the uk the restrictions are
just getting worse um you know you can't you
that finance um and barclays bank have now
had an issue between them um yeah i believe you i
believe you can't actually even send from buying
uh from barclays sorry to finance anymore so yeah
do you believe that bitcoin could ever be banned
um i mean you can't ban bitcoin right
um i don't believe you can ban bitcoin
you can't you can't you can't do that like
from day one bitcoin is global from day one
bitcoin is censorship resistant like you know
uh the genius of satoshi you know it's kind of
just looked at what are the possibilities and
what's not right it's literally almost impossible
to do that right now you know if you want to
do a 51 attack it's very expensive to do that
right and um we're seeing mining as well becoming
more decentralized so i see yeah miners moving out
of china you know into other jurisdictions uh and
if you look at it in the short term it's looking
like a bad thing but you know the longer term
outlook is that um this is a good thing right
so you have more miners in russia you have miners
in the u.s you have miners moving into europe uh
other parts of asia like i think i think i think
you know more than ever it's solid find a future
of bitcoin that bitcoin cannot be banned right you
can't go to china and just get most of the miners
off the network of course we have the difficult
uh t uh algorithm that also adjust that adjust
automatically as well so i don't think they can do
that um i think that we try um i think that's like
a huge war that will come you know especially when
the stats are launching their cbdc's and what's
not right um but well i think i think bitcoin is
it's in good hands um the people the people will
surely be on the side of bitcoin it's not going
to be easy but then i'm sure that uh whole conca
yeah it's so fascinating um because you're totally
right you know you have the decentralized network
i'm totally on the same side of that um you know
you can't actually ban that and if one country
were to ban it or you know increase hostility
like we saw in china then they just moved right
so that's totally fine and i think what also blew
my mind was that um so for people that don't know
luno they actually sponsor this podcast and they
um are a uk and they're also based in nigeria
their cryptocurrency exchange and we spoke
about this a few months ago and i actually
double checked with luno this is a fact so when
they did um when nigeria did that clampdown
and bitcoin started to trade at a premium on
luno mind-blowing that's crazy yeah i mean
we love that there's there's there's
demand there's this there's always
so right now um you know unlike um
earlier yes uh right now with bitcoin
you know if you send bitcoin to me over here
in nigeria i could um there are so many ways
for me to liquidate it in like less than 10
minutes right and having around my bank account
like um since i've moved so fast um you know
you have a vibrant community of people using
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies for you know
remittances whatever they want to use it for
and um i think times have changed and just to
you know just to go back like a minute to a
minute ago to what we're talking about um i did
centralization of bitcoin now it's it's not that
uh bitcoin it's it's uh in a way also
it's kind of like a jubilee school tool
right that if one country tries to ban it right
or move miners out of it another country is
going to take advantage of that and that's what
we're seeing right now with with china china is
saying hey leave our country and all of that
and there are many countries saying hey come
like accepting them and you know doing uh just
giving them the best uh you know of um services
to you know set up their that their cause uh in
their country so i think it's gonna be uh you know
even in geopolitical space uh bitcoin has that
um thing to you know put one country you know hey
you want to sanction me then yeah i'm going into
bitcoin right i look at the case of el salvador
and all of those kind of things so i think
um i think we're gonna have interesting times
yeah i mean el salvador you bring that up
that's a fascinating one isn't it because
they're so small right they're a tiny country with
just over a population of just over six million
people the amount of hostility that they have
received from the u.s from global organizations
from i kind of get into it right now it's just it
just blows my mind you know it just really shows
you the power of bitcoin um and how people know
that's where you know that's that's the thing
i think authorities know um but you mentioned
cbdc's and nigeria are working on one aren't they
yeah i had sue um and you know it's just just
like everyone i'm just i'm just waiting to see
what what comes of of it right um just waiting to
see what comes of it it's kind of you know we're
not gonna let this happen but then we're doing it
so is it a case of just doing what everyone says
they're doing or is this a case of do you really
believe in this thing that you're talking about
and you know so yeah i think sometimes yeah
they'll do it no but the thing is i think they'll
do it everybody's gonna do it china's already
um you know china's already moving ahead with
theirs i think theirs is already actually active
in beijing i saw some news about it today actually
which wasn't good but anyway um i mean this is
sort of control so they don't definitely want
to do it yeah oh yeah yeah no absolutely and
for those that don't know it's simply because
it's going to be um highly centralized that is
the problem it's going to be highly centralized
and um you speak about this war between the two
i'd love to hear more about that because i also
share a really similar um opinion so tell me
more about that war that you sort of envisage
uh yeah so uh i mean if you're talking
about the war between the nation state and
bitcoin or between two nation states uh with yeah
so um when we're talking about the war between
nation states and bitcoin right um it's really
more of uh which country is gonna come all out to
actually show that this particular technology
is uh undermining their control right now yeah
um i mean we've seen glimpses of that with china
right yeah uh we've seen this of that with china
china is trying to uh their cbdc is coming out
and you know suddenly they are moving bitcoin
uh miners out of china because one thing
about cb diseases is that once they go
live and people discover that these are actually
true tools of control and more oppression then
people are going to even want to opt in to
things like bitcoin the more because right
now asides bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
what you have is cash is like the next private
thing that we have with money there's nothing
wrong with privacy i think that's that's part
of the thing that they you know they fail to
understand there's nothing wrong with privacy
you know i mean i don't have to be doing
anything bad right to demand privacy you know
what i had for breakfast today you know it's
my personal business right i only i can only
choose to let you know if i want to right
but is it a bad thing that i had my breakfast
you know no it's not a bad thing so i think that
you know when they start doing these things um a
lot of more people come to the consciousness
that um we've been controlled for so long
and if this were actually doing central bank
digital currencies it means that there's something
in these digital currencies you know so what's the
difference between bitcoin and these ones right
now when they bring out their central bank digital
currencies of course uh they wouldn't want it to
coexist with bitcoin rights because i mean that's
the anticipation of whatever they're doing and
however they do it no matter how they do it
the clear difference between their uh coins and
bitcoin is the monetary policy they're not going
to change their monetary policy it's just in fact
if anything it allows them to mean more money much
easier you know at the press of a button they've
maintained much more much more money so i think
that you know there's going to be a coordinated
effort um you know between these countries uh
to yeah you know uh fight against bitcoin and
even i i see that um as well you have these
bigger countries and more developed countries
who control the likes of imf uh you know trying to
put pressure on smaller countries so like what's
in return el salvador right uh you probably
see you'll probably see them telling african
countries that maybe one of the demands one of
the conditions in which we're going to give you
a loan or a grant or whatever is that you know you
have to bank bitcoin in your country and you know
they probably just do it yeah i mean it's not
impossible it's it's it's something that you
can do we have to be able to think of the whole
worst case scenario because when you see the
comments that come from these people then you see
that like really i mean just see what happened
with somebody just showed your hands anyone
that was doubting right this was clear right
and bitcoin is a central bank bitcoin is
actually we think of bitcoin as so many
things but we forget that bitcoin is actually also
fighting against central banking because bitcoin
himself is a central bank right but one central
bank one monetary policy that doesn't change
that you know doesn't discriminate that everyone
across the world someone in the u.s cannot tell
me not to use bitcoin you know or tell me how
to use my bitcoin right it doesn't discriminate
but someone in the u.s can tell me how to use
my nara which is what is happening right now
because through setting government
policies through imf through the world bank
who controls money in my country right i can't
that that whole thing trickles down to me so
the whole council on the effects and everything
industry cools down to me but with bitcoin this
is like totally different so i think it's going to
be interesting in the next decade most especially
yeah i mean i don't think a lot of these countries
have africa's best interests at heart no no no
they have i did come on they know i did never
have they never they probably never will so yeah
yeah exactly so to be able to have a
currency which is independent from these con
these countries um and their sanctions and
their blackmail and all these sorts of fun
things all these exciting tools of control um
it's pretty insane but you made a point about um
people will see the truth in cbdc's
and then pick bitcoin but i disagree um
i have a concern um that cbdc's will be marketed
as this new shiny piece of technology that will
save the day obviously you and i and everybody
watching know that that obviously knows that
that's not the case um but i worry that they'll
think because right now people do think bitcoin is
kind of criminal so when they look to
cbdc's they'll be like oh this is better
it's government-backed you know it's supported by
the government the government says this is okay
so education is going to be really important
don't you think yeah yeah um i quite agree with
them with some you know your thoughts on that i
mean uh obviously it's even the same thing right
now that's happening with bitcoin right um a lot
of people still think it's used for just criminal
purposes it's a bad thing and what's not and it's
because we have taken time to understand it you
know do the research ask questions and we've seen
it right so of course what i was trying to say was
with the cb disease you're gonna have uh people
who are also gonna see this not everyone but it's
gonna be the trigger point for you know another
set of people to leave to want to opt out of
that system because they probably fall victim of
you know uh you know noun they don't have cash
because one thing disabilities is they're going
to try to eliminate cash there's a war on cash
they're still ongoing i believe that when cbc's
come they're going to accelerate that war on cash
right now when that one cash goes then uh
you know it's it becomes a whole thing and
uh of course you can displace the part of um
education i think education is really important
uh you know people have to understand why the
whys of money at uh in the first place because for
someone the fact that he has one thousand error
in his bank account uh today and he comes up to it
12 months later and he still one thousand error
that's what matters to the person person doesn't
care about purchasing power the person doesn't
care about inflation and whatnot we have to be
able to get people to see that this is not just uh
as it is this is not just what they tell you right
like there's something behind it and i think um
as everyone the community we are about to you
know put put put a lot of effort uh into you know
educating people which is what i keep saying that
uh the most important work for everyone right now
is for us to um on board as many people as we can
before this war comes because when this war comes
we're gonna need the numbers we're gonna need
the wealth to uh fight this was gonna be fights
of misinformation and all of that kind of thing
so so that's how i see it playing out i
tell you bernard i think the war has started
it has started i'm telling you i feel it um but
what's what's the education um like um in nigeria
when it comes to bitcoin do people know much about
it is there this kind of concern and fear around
it that we certainly have in the uk i think people
think bitcoin and crypto is just some kind of
weird dirty thing yeah i i think um so so from
you know my own personal experience uh talking to
people um you know those who have never gotten
and all of that um it's more of i think less
less from the criminal uh you know aspect of
it it's more of that fear of even starting
you know how does it even work like yeah i i
wanna put just ten dollars in it like but how
does even work right they have no clue how it
works right and you know sometimes you go on
google but they prefer someone explains it to them
and they get it to do because assistance nigeria
is a very low trust environment so typically i
would want someone who is doing it to want to
maybe probably take me through it right of course
we have groups so we have we have people who do it
as a business right teaching people about bitcoin
what cryptocurrencies and well i think they've i
think generally they've actually done a fantastic
job of onboarding people uh into the space right
even if they charge i mean they gotta eat right
but um i think they've done i think i think that
they're kind of some of the unsung heroes when
it comes to onboarding people uh you know onto
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies uh in nigeria
so these people have groups they probably educate
like maybe 20 people a month 30 people a month uh
you know even if people pay yeah right and then
they keep they keep those groups growing mentoring
people in there and you know they're not out there
people don't know that people don't see them but
you know yeah again they're doing the legwork and
and we're just banking on that network effect
that you know if i see this person doing it and
he has taught me i'm also going to go and start my
own group and teach other people and you know and
then it grows um that way yeah it's great to hear
that there's some education um i want to actually
ask you about um other cryptocurrencies in nigeria
because i mentioned earlier that i have spoken to
a lot of guys who are building their own
protocols with their own protocols come
their own tokens and their own cryptos so um
what how do i put this what else is going on
is there any interest in anything else um i
know somebody's actually written in the comments
people want to make quick money right so the next
thing they hear if elon musk is talking about
dodge coin you know uh people in the community
probably feel like okay this guy is just um just
naming dodge coin and stuff but people actually
take him serious right right people knew to this
place actually take him really serious and you
know um i'm just remembering the whole dutch coin
creed who are in as well um the shebai you have
someone think i have one million shiva and you
know that's probably lost value right now you know
and it's just uh crazy i mean for a lot of them
first time of course um for a lot of us first time
we got him we go bonds um so i i guess it's just
learning our lessons and doing but they're
interesting projects as well coming out of nigeria
so of course there's um send finance so basically
yeah those are the guys cooperative unions
so they're doing cooperative unions are you
know on the blockchain with their own stuff
bundle is doing amazing stuff you know um you
know they've kind of unlocked some kind of
growth marketing in the space and kind of you know
blew up really fast uh you have bicones you know
uh luna since the band luna hasn't been uh really
active in nigeria i mean back then they were
really like you know uh probably the biggest
you know because they rely on the banks right
yes yes yes yes um yeah and of course there's
paxful right so of course on the information
to to parks for right um you know a lot of people
just probably just like run their businesses uh on
top of that uh as well so yeah these coins are
there finance you know finance you know almost
everyone has the finance out they just trade their
tokens and you know that kind of thing but i think
it's interesting i'm seeing people getting into
uh there's this group called um web free breach
i think they are teaching people how to build on
ethereum and just technical uh development and
you know people just uh there are a couple
of interesting projects um around so yeah
yeah that is interesting so how's ethereum
um what's the ethereum sentiment are people
interested in that i mean i know it's not really
regarded as the store of value but given web three
is uh is that quite popular yeah yeah i think it's
quite popular over here in nigeria so um for a lot
of people they hold bitcoin and ethereum right you
have the guys who tell that you know html is gonna
flip i have one friend that has been telling me
how to run with flipped bitcoin for the past three
years you know he's gonna flip this so ethereum
has a really strong um community over here in
nigeria and um i think um in fairness to them they
have more developers going into uh trying to build
d5 applications and trying to build um smart
contracts on material you know trying to
integrate it into everyday finance and whatnot
so i think it's pretty big here yeah this is a
thing so for me bitcoin is the store of value um
you know i would tell people to buy bitcoin but
i would never ever tell them to buy anything
else um but i am i'm bullish on ethereum um
mainly because um sorry i have a fan and it's
blowing everything because it's very hot and
um yeah so i'm really really bullish on ethereum
just because i feel like the entire internet is
attempting to be built on ethereum i'm not saying
that it's going to be but it's attempting to and
especially in africa you know when it comes to
decentralized finance lending and borrowing i mean
it's like a no-brainer that that to me that
also was something which just blew my mind um
no not yet um even though apart from zen finance
of course right yeah um i mean i personally feel
that you know a lot of distance can still be built
on bitcoin right but just as you're saying uh you
can't you can't you can't you you can't displace
network effects right i think ethereum has strong
network effects um in nigeria as well right so you
can't really displace and say hey look just go to
the gutters you know you're not gonna of course
i i don't tell people to buy ethereum i don't
tell people to buy any other tokens or whatever
it's just purely uh bitcoin just like you right
but of course you can't ignore this you can't um
ignore uh stable coins the fact that stable coins
run on a serial man you know people people
always get surprised when i tell them that
you know something like tita actually started on
the bitcoin blockchain right on what they call it
only i forgotten the name of the project right
so um people people are really bullish on that
people want to build all these smart contracts
people feel that there are a lot of things that
they can build on top of ethereum to do things for
them and you have actually more developers going
into building ethereum applications uh over here
learning how to of course uh personally i would
prefer that you know we have more developers going
into bitcoin where i feel that we need to do more
work uh on that um you know i think chain could
have started something similar around that side
but um i think uh when it comes to developers
it has been taken personally i did something
with um consensus studios in 2018 uh to build um
ethereum stuff right um you know the antideveloper
academy stuff and so it's kind of it's taking
the lead when it comes to getting developers
out of nigeria out of africa essentially that
bitcoin we need to kind of do to catch up as well
hopefully we lighten it as well yeah it's it's
so amazing i'm i just i just love it like i love
a good solution you know to a problem which is
just feels so unfixable unsolvable like a lifetime
kind of problem you know um so thank you so much
like honestly it's been so fascinating learning
uh more about this from you um where can people
learn more about you and what are you up to next
um okay so people can find me on twitter
bernard on the para p-a-r-a-h or just
search for uh bidding up uh b-i-t-n-o-b on
twitter i'm sure that my name come on you know
under people you can find me there uh big-nub and
we're working on a couple of interesting things
so working on bringing um lightning uh you
know to to nigeria and to other africans
uh you know very soon yeah in the next couple
of weeks you know you can be able to send
you know even just one dollar worth of bitcoin
from anywhere in the world down to nigeria you
know instantly for like a penny uh you know so
i'm really excited about that um yeah we have
a couple of other things coming um interest on
savings um you know i people are really picking
up the gta because i'm picking up championed dc in
africa and we're really seeing people you know are
loving it and doing more dc as well so yeah
i'm really those are those are the things
we're working on and you know just want to push
more to see how things go yeah i think it's all
so amazing um you know i really appreciate the
work that you're doing um thank you for me this
has just been the the thing like i said at the
beginning which just grabbed me and pulled me
into the space and made me stay the opportunities
and not just for people um in nigeria and the rest
of africa but for everyone really um you know
it's just it's just opportunity to be honest um
so bernard i want to thank you so much it's been
such a pleasure having you um and it's been so
great to get your insight given you're literally
based in nigeria right now so thank you so much i
enjoyed the chat thank you for having me bye yeah
and guys thank you so much for watching um what
i will do is um if you are based in nigeria
and you do want to buy bitcoin i will leave
a luna link for you um i'll ask the guys we'll get
one i think they could potentially do something
where you get like ten dollars i'm not 100 sure um
but i'll speak to them and i'll try and leave the
link in um the youtube description so thanks so
much for watching please don't forget to subscribe
so you never miss an amazing video and
i will see you all next week bye bye